We Begin this hour with some breaking
news coming out of India at least 60
people have died after a suspension
bridge collapsed in the city of morby
which is in Gujarat State local media
reporting that several hundred people
fell into the water below rescue
operations are ongoing let's speak to
the journalist haresh Jala he is in
amadaba the capital of Gujarat State
thank you for your time sir what is your
understanding of what happened
uh uh around six uh 6 30 p.m the hanging
bridge that we call a suspension bridge
collapse this bridge was reopened after
renovation just four days ago and
without any Fitness certificate
according to the morbi town chief
executive officer no official Bridge use
certificate was issued yet the private
contractor who is having the contract to
renovate and maintain this suspension
bridge he reopened it and allowed
visitors to visit the bridge
uh for primary information is some 400
to 500 persons were there on that very
moment when this bridge has fall up from
right middle and till this moment the
local authorities have confirmed 77
deaths including children and women and
at least 150 are rescued and been taken
to the hospital where they have been
treated at some seven National Disaster
Response Force Team uh 50 Germans of
Navy and other rescue operation teams
are being pressed in to rescue the
drowned or trapped people it seems that
uh the rescue operation will continue
entire night because there is one fear
that there was a heavy water flow in the
Machu River so there is a possibility
that few bodies might have swained away
kilometers away from the accident site
okay the figure we have for the number
of people who've died so far 60 you're
saying 77 but presumably it is it's
still a fast-moving situation so we
don't have the exact figure yet
what is your understanding of why there
were so many people on this bridge I
mean another journalist I was speaking
to was putting the figure down to over a
thousand tourists on the bridge at that
time why were there so many people on
that bridge
well thousand is a two huge bigger
figure see the bridge size its length is
233 meters and just four feet wide so
you can uh just have a rough estimate
that it cannot accommodate 1000 people
at a time now the question is why so
many people were there on this very
bridge at this moment see this bridge is
almost 150 years old what's uh last two
years it was closed for the public use
or visit because it had stipulated and
it needed renovation now the contract
was given seven months ago the
contractor in hurry had reopened without
due valid feasibility report and allowed
visitors to visit right this is
just to interrupt you there this is what
I'm finding a little confusing even if
it was a private contractor why why was
it why why was the why did the state
allow that bridge to open if there was
no safety inspection passed
exactly now the chief executive officer
of the local Authority he is claiming
that he the contractor has not taken any
official permission from the local
Authority they on their own house resume
this operation allowed people to visit
now it's a question whether contractor
can illegally do so or why the local
Authority was sleeping for last five
four five days because this was open on
26 today we are on 23 on 30th October so
already four days have passed the local
authorities were sleeping because it was
there in the local media that these
Bridges open for public people are
paying 17 and 12 rupees charges to visit
this bridge 12 rupees for under under 15
and 17 is for adult so that means that
contractor was in hurry to make money
and so without feasibility and fitness
certificate he resumed this operation
what a terrible tragedy so so what
you're saying is this this bridge was a
it was a tourist destination essentially
that that's why people were coming to
this bridge
yeah exactly uh this bridge see
basically this bridge was uh constructed
some 150 years ago by then ruler uh
now that bridge had developed some um
erosions so the local authorities had
closed it to you for two years then it
went for a renovation now the renovation
work was really completed what was it on
a trial that is a question of
Investigation the state government has
constituted a five member inquiry
committee now they will look into all
technical aspects of structural design
and its Fitness and that will that will
tell us whether this Village was capable
to carry 500 passengers or visitors at a
time or not
many thanks for your time a journalist
speaking to us there from the capital of
Gujarat state
thank you